Reality is messy and unpredictable.
So it’s only fitting that shows marketing
themselves as reality television have more
than a few surprises.
And with the boom in reality programming,
some shows have gone over-and-above in the
hopes of being noticed by audiences.
But even though there is no shortage of entertainment,
some situations are just so outstanding that
we thought they deserved a shoutout.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Most Shocking
Reality TV Moments Of All Time.
Jersey Shore, S01E04 “Fade to Black”
We all know someone who gets a little silly
when they drink.
But for six seasons, that’s what the cast
of Jersey Shore did for a living.
The gang would dress up, get wasted, and usually
engage in some degree of buffoonery.
The cast’s most ridiculous member is also
its tiniest.
At just over 4 and a half feet, Nicole “Snooki”
Polizzi had an incredible ability to stir
up trouble wherever she went.
And in the series’ fourth episode, it backfired.
Thinking that someone was stealing drinks,
Snooki ruffled some Jersey feathers, and got
punched in the face for it.
The result is one reality TV moment that will
go down in infamy.
The Bachelor, S13E10 “After the Final Rose”
At this point The Bachelor is a reality television
institution.
Since 2002 audiences have followed the stories
of eligible men searching for The One.
And thanks to it’s success, there is an
entire universe of dating shows to choose
from.
What starts as a group of about twenty five
potential mates eventually gets narrowed down
to one, and marriage is the end goal.
As you can probably imagine, the competition
is through the roof.
So when it comes down to only two women, the
choice should be pretty obvious at that point,
right?
Wrong.
After the Romeo from Season 13 proposed to
one lady, he turned around and changed his
mind… on national television.
Saying the breakup was “public” feels
like an understatement, since over 17 million
people watched it happen.
America’s Next Top Model, S04E07 “The
Girl Who Sends Tyra Over The Edge”
Being on Americas Next Top Model is an honor.
And anyone who acts otherwise is setting themselves
up for a lecture from Tyra Banks.
One of the model hopefuls in the shows fourth
cycle learned that the hard way.
After displaying what Banks felt was a bad
attitude, model Tiffany Richardson came under
fire at the elimination ceremony.
An argument between the two women escalated
quickly, which culminated in Banks full-on
yelling at Richardson.
Obviously, Richardson was the one eliminated
that week.
But we’re willing to bet that even though
she didn’t win, she’s one of the most
memorable contestants in the show’s 22 season
history.
Keeping Up With The Kardashians, S10E16 “Vanity
Unfair”
Shining a light on anyones family dynamics
is a bold move, and the Kardashian clan have
been doing it since 2007.
When news of Caitlyn Jenner’s transition
hit the media, many were stunned.
And while the reactions were mixed, the news
prompted a lot of discussion about gender
transition.
Considering his who her family is, it should
come as no surprise that the intensely personal
subject was at the center of some of the most
popular episodes of Keeping Up With The Kardashians.
But the moment that made the biggest splash
was Jenner’s interview with Vanity Fair
magazine.
In fact, so many people were interested that
a spinoff I Am Cait was created to focus just
on her.
The Hills, S06E12 “All Good Things…”
For just under a decade, reality television
was run by a bunch of kids from California.
After the end of MTV’s Laguna Beach, some
of the characters moved on to the follow-up
show called The Hills.
A show loaded with teenage angst.
Lauren Conrad moved from her childhood neighborhood
to the big city, and audiences were beside
her every step of the way as she fumbled her
way to adulthood.
That is, until fellow Laguna-alum Kristin
Cavallari took over.
Fans took sides in every argument and were
supposedly seeing real-life drama.
Until the last shot of the series, anyway,
in which the camera zooms out to show that
the scene was being shot on a soundstage.
And just like that, it ruined it’s own legacy.
Survivor, S07E11 “The Great Lie”
Ask any fan and they’ll tell you: Survivor
is all about the challenges.
Seeing our everyday conveniences suddenly
transformed into luxuries is one of it’s
most interesting aspects.
One thing the survivors find the hardest is
being away from their loved ones, and perhaps
the most coveted reward comes in the form
of a visit with a family member.
During the show’s seventh season, the winner
of that visit was a contestant known as Jonny
Fairplay.
After a friend revealed that Jonny’s grandmother
died, the tribe voted to let Jonny have the
time with his friend given the unfortunate
news.
But shortly after, it was discovered that
Jonny engineered the entire situation, and
his grandma was just fine.
Miss Universe 2015
Of all the people in a pageant, the host has
it the easiest.
They don’t have to answer hard-hitting political
questions or parade around in a swimsuit.
And although they may have the most camera
time, they’re usually pretty forgettable.
Unless you’re Steve Harvey.
When Harvey hosted the 2015 Miss Universe
pageant, he almost made it out unscathed.
But then he announced the wrong winner.
That’s right.
Even though he was physically holding a card
with the winner’s name on it, the crown
went to the wrong contestant.
After realizing his mistake, Harvey was genuinely
mortified.
And, like the classy ladies they are, Miss
Colombia and Miss Philippines handled the
mixup with grace.
The Bachelorette, S11E01 “Week 1, Part 1:
Limo Arrivals”
Given the aforementioned universe of dating
shows, it can be hard for show runners to
keep their content fresh.
But because there are so few limitations on
reality television, people behind the scenes
are always scheming about the next possible
twist.
This has led to some pretty interesting variations
on old classics.
And the premiere episode of the eleventh season
of The Bachelorette is no exception.
Audiences expected to be greeted by one eligible
bachelorette and twentysomething potential
mates.
So when two bachelorettes emerged and the
mates were asked to vote on which one should
stay, the show’s whole foundation was rocked.
American Idol, 12E03 “Charlotte Auditions”
American Idol has gone through a few different
judging combinations over it’s 15 season
run.
For the most part they’ve all been pretty
well-respected in the industry, but when Mariah
Carey showed up, critics took notice.
Given the songstress’ diva reputation, audiences
ate up every snide remark she made.
And when she butted heads with fellow judge
Nicki Minaj over a contestant named Summer,
the exchange made an impression.
To this day it’s hard to understand what
their argument was actually about, but it
was a big deal nonetheless.
And for a show that many pundits argued was
on it’s last legs, the tiff provided a much-needed
popularity boost.
Australia’s Next Top Model, S06E11 “Live
Finale”
A few years before Steve Harvey announced
the wrong winners name on a global scale,
Sarah Murdoch had the same experience on a
slightly smaller level.
As the host of Australia’s Next Top Model,
Murdoch had the responsibility of declaring
the competition’s winner on live T.V. Given
it’s unpredictable nature, even the most
seasoned veterans stumble from time to time.
And yet again, the wrong person was named
the victor.
When Murdoch realized the mistake, she apologized
profusely and admitted that the incorrect
name had been announced into her earpiece.
Both models took a second to understand what
had happened, and were good sports about it.
Whoopsie!
What do you think of our list?
Did we miss any other shocking reality TV
moments?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.